at the cause in tottenham they aren't
exactly dancing with delight at how
covered passports will impact business
it's completely messed the market up
yeah people
people's confidence has gone maybe not
getting the bar revenue for that which
is it just majorly messes up your
business model i think we are unfairly
targeted to be honest
it isn't the only business now legally
required to carry out covid's status
checks the rules affect any nightclub or
indoor unseated venue with a capacity of
more than 500 people unseated outdoor
venues that hold more than 4 000 and any
venue with more than 10 000 people which
makes the very british tradition of
football at christmas a bit more
complicated this year
it is inconvenient for some people and i
have to tell fans you know prepare and
know what you need to do in order to get
into the stadium of course if you're not
vaccinated you can also do a lateral
flow test
but it will probably take a little bit
longer to get into the stadium
it is a complicated and contradictory
set of lines drawn up by the government
work from home but you can have a
christmas party now if that party's in
the pub and there's music and dancing
that's fine but if you end up going to a
nightclub after that then you all have
to prove that you've been double jabbed
go to the cinema or the theater and
because you're seated it's fine just to
wear a mask i think it is kind of
unfavorable it takes away people's
freedom it takes away people's
human rights essentially i think it's
your responsibility to kind of read up
and make sure that you're up to date
with the latest rules and know what you
need to do to kind of help everyone else
out each to their own i'm definitely
pro-choice but i'm also pro-common sense
i absolutely agree with the rules but i
just don't think
they're
sufficient enough to protect people
properly
the venue's hoping to recoup losses
before christmas the timing couldn't be
worse rather than encouraging people to
get vaccinated they fear it'll only
discourage people from going out katie
spencer sky news